NIGHT.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYONE.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE HAVE SAD NEWS.
WRITER, PHYSICIAN, AND LONGTIME
CONTRIBUTOR CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER
DIED TODAY AT THE AGE OF 68.
HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE, HE
MADE IN 1964, AND THEIR SON,
DANIEL.
ALSO MOURNING HIS DEATH ARE HIS
MANY FRIENDS AT THIS NETWORK AND
MILLIONS OF VIEWERS WHO KNEW AND
LOVED CHARLES FROM WATCHING HIM
EVERY NIGHT AS THEY DID.
ASK ANY FOX ANCHOR, WHO IS THE
PERSON PEOPLE AT THE AIRPORT ASK
ABOUT THE MOST, EVERY SINGLE ONE
WILL TELL YOU,
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
FOX VIEWERS LOVED CHARLES, AND
IT WASN'T BECAUSE HE PANDERED TO
THEM.
HE DIDN'T.
SOMETIMES HE TOOK POSITIONS THEY
DISLIKED OR HATED, BUT VIEWERS
NOT ONLY FORGIVE HIM FOR DOING
THAT, THEY SEEMED TO LOVE HIM
MORE.
THEY COULD SEE HIS BRILLIANCE
BUT THEY COULD ALSO FEEL HIS
SINCERITY.
CHARLES ALWAYS SAID WHAT HE
THOUGHT WAS TRUE.
HE WAS AN HONEST AND GENUINELY
DECENT MAN AND IT SHONE THROUGH.
CHARLES ALSO MAY BE THE BRAVEST
MAN I MET PERSONALLY.
IT TAKES COURAGE TO STAY
CHEERFUL AND HUMANE FOR 68
YEARS, DOUBLY SO GIVEN THE
REMARKABLE CHALLENGES THAT HE
FACED IN THE LAST 44 OF THOSE
YEARS.
BUT HE DID IT.
CHARLES WAS TOTALLY